we got this from The Daily Mail targets
market cap slumps by 15 billion amid
backlash over tuck friendly swimsuits
analysts say retail giant is
hemorrhaging customers to Walmart oh now
all that stuff we're talking about I'm
just gonna sit back and say we're
winning yes yeah you hate to see it oh
no yeah we'll go see it regular people
we saw we saw parents rising up saying
get this stuff away from my kids we're
seeing Gamers who have long been in the
culture where in fact Gamers started the
culture War back with gamergate now
still being very active and um now
taking Center Stage once again and now
we have the Bud Light effect Target
Kohl's North Face these companies are
getting slammed by people who are just
saying I'm fed up when did the target
boycott begin middle of May it was on
May 21st when things just started to
plummet and uh yeah May 17th or
something two and a half weeks ago wow
people are just tired of it yeah and the
great thing is is that right now the
free market does still work right we're
watching that we're watching that as it
relates to Target but in a not too
distant future if we don't continue to
push back against this and look I think
we are starting to chip away at this ESG
issue we are now Vanguard has dropped
out of the Net Zero uh asset managers
Alliance now I think they're still doing
it they're still involved in it but
they're starting to hedge you're seeing
people start to hatch and
these folks are going to have to learn
their lesson in free market economics
guess who shops at Target uh not your uh
woke liberal Elites they're driving
Subarus to Whole Foods right so Riley so
I wanted to follow up with you you're
running for a very important in the
second congressional district here in
West Virginia I know um ESG has been a
big part of your campaign so far are
there any other big issues that you're
especially concerned about yeah
certainly obviously we've done a lot in
the state Treasures Office which I'm in
currently on ESG but uh some of the
other big ones is China's something that
we're going to have to contend with uh
as a country and moving forward I mean
the idea that we're still making
Pharmaceuticals over there I think is
hugely problematic they're going to be
one of the biggest uh one of the biggest
threats I think in the near and
long-term future for us but domestically
where I'm focused and I run what's
called The Hope Scholarship here in West
Virginia it's an educational savings
account we must and underline this we
must eliminate the Department of
Education it has to go wow it has to go
big Proclamation right there no the
Department of Education must be
eliminated if you look at when Jimmy
Carter instituted that to where we are
now we used to be number one in
education in the world and where we are
now
it is not working and so we need to move
that money back to the States and then
take a portion of that money to create
educational savings accounts all around
the country because not as many states
are as free as West Virginia but every
American child whether in California or
New York needs to have educational
opportunity and choice so that's going
to be a big issue as well during the
world I wanted to follow up with you
there's a very contentious Republican
presidential primary going on I'm not
sure if you heard what do you think of
the primaries so far I have heard I've
heard a little bit about that uh I have
endorsed uh president Trump and so that
is certainly who I'm supporting can I
follow up with you on that I talked a
lot about this I talked about it with
Seamus yesterday I see that you were
endorsed by the West Virginia for Life
yes in a lot of Trump's statements he
actually sounds less pro-life than Ron
DeSantis does I think Ron DeSantis was
trying to push six weeks bans while
Trump puts out tweets blaming um the
abortion issue for Trump for Republicans
losing in the midterms so how do you
square you know supporting endorsing
Trump and being so pro-life when there
are other more pro-life people in the
field yeah you know I've seen some of
those statements I can't say I'm
necessarily happy with that in West
Virginia we passed a ban and it's zero
weeks uh in West Virginia so obviously
when was that uh that was in the last
session it passed so this January yeah
so that's Virginia always gets ignored
when these things happen yeah so that's
law in West Virginia there are some
exemptions in it uh rape incest uh life
of mother uh but uh yep so that's what
happened to West Virginia I I don't even
understand the incest one though like I
understand it's bad don't get me wrong I
think it shouldn't happen
when it comes to the issue of rape that
I certainly understand for for
exceptions and it's a horrible thing
still but I don't I don't understand the
conservative argument on why incest uh
yeah I I don't I don't really understand
that one either
um like if the baby is not viable and
can't survive there's not a question of
exceptions it's an issue of like well
the baby can't survive if the incest
results in deformity now again obviously
incest should not be happening right but
I just don't understand what the
conservative argument is why we give
that an exception also like how often is
that happening like I don't what I've
heard from conservatives is that it's
it's it's meant to refer to child abuse
right you know like parents yeah and I
guess at the end of the day in like rape
still covered by that like that's why I
just don't understand I mean it's a
eugenic argument it's a Eugenics
argument that that incest results in
abnormality and I'm like I get that but
wouldn't the conservative position like
I'm I'm more pro-choice than probably
you guys I think I don't know about the
lottery yeah 14 weeks so I just don't
understand the conservative argument
that's awesome yeah I don't I don't
really get it I have another question
for you
um
so you come from a political family
um your grandfather was he served in the
house Reps for a decade then he was also
the Governor here in Western Virginia
for a decade your aunt is currently
serving
um in West Virginia as the junior
Senator uh Michelle
how would you respond to somebody who
says we've seen enough nepotism in our
country and government already and that
you you undoubtedly do benefit from the
family name your aunt still keeps her
the she has a hyphenated last name to
still keep that more name how would you
respond to somebody that you're
benefiting from your family name and you
know not necessarily your Merit yeah
look it's a great question I don't want
anybody to vote for me because of my
name uh I want them to vote for Riley
and you know it is a fair point that
people make on that and I wouldn't argue
for a minute but look I'm not running my
name I'm running on my record and look I
got a very conservative record and I
think it stands for itself and I think
it stands on its own
you know don't vote for me because my
last name I I you know and if that's an
issue for you I totally understand I
just take a look at my record I don't I
don't really care like Jeb didn't make
it Jeb was trash but part of why they
get some of some of that bump initially
is a result of the last name same with
Kennedy I think a lot of Kennedy support
just comes from the last name same with
the bushes same with the clintons I mean
but rand's pretty based yeah ran tall
yeah I don't think that I would have had
the opportunity though had it not been
for his father and I'm not knocking your
credentials but the benefit from your
grandfather was very influential but and
your aunt is still very influential well
let me just uh does does Ron have any
other kids does Rand have any siblings I
don't know if if there was like a like a
a third Rand at Paul and she was running
I would I'd be like I don't know he's
the third one in the field but like
let's make sure and I will I would vote
for at a heartbeat like anybody who fell
for any Apple that fell from that tree
gets my vote but isn't that nepotism
then you're voting them because
his favorite I'm half kidding I'm half
kid You could argue that someone that is
related to someone else is the most
qualified person for the job and in
those situations
favoritism and therefore not nepotism
what is inepitism uh voting for someone
because their father that's not nepotism
because the nepotism it means that like
you get someone a job because they're
related now baptism is the practice
among those with power influence of
favoring relatives I yeah but that mean
that's right Riley's not appointed yeah
I think you undoubtedly benefit from the
name but the follow-up would be the
Thanksgiving dinners must be interesting
I don't know are you going to get the
endorsement from
I might be in trouble if I don't uh did
she endorse you I don't yeah I mean uh
yeah she supports what I do she's
supporting what I'm around she's the
junior senator in West Virginia she is
Tyler Shelly more capito so we're not
fans captive I know you're not and look
why aren't you fan because she uh signed
on to Red Flag laws and then lied about
it
what do you think of that look I don't
support red flag laws and and look we're
we're related she's my aunt I love her
but you know doesn't mean we're gonna
agree on everything right so it's I
don't support it yeah I don't I don't
support any restrictions on the Second
Amendment whatsoever we don't need to do
yes we don't need to do anything new as
it relates to Second Amendment yes we do
we need to repeal oh yes yeah we have to
repeal I'm talking about moving forward
on any type of uh restrictions
whatsoever hey look we've been winning
on 2A across
if you look at the maps of gun rights
it's just been Victory after Victory
after Victory I I gotta be honest I
think people they hear us complain about
bad things and they get black pilled and
they're like oh Tim's black pill and he
says and I'm like look man just because
I'm saying like hey thing over here is
really bad does not mean the totality of
things are are moving in a positive way
that's why I often try to say like look
I know it's getting really really bad
but my vision really is the end result
is going to be awesome stuff happening
yes like we we the reason we are in a
conflict culturally with like the
targets the Bud Lights the
Anheuser-Busch or whatever is because we
are now standing up and pushing back
when you get sick you are already
infected that's that's paying your
feeling is fighting back against it so
so the stuff we're going through now
means we have engaged and we are seeing
Victory after Victory after Victory so
I'm feeling pretty good I think it could
get bad especially with the Trump
indictments and all that stuff it is
getting bad yeah but I think it's that
we're seeing when when when someone is
drowning and they can't breathe they
start thrashing around as violently as
possible and they say if you're trying
to rescue them you've got to approach
them from behind and lift them up
otherwise they'll drag you down the
machine is in a death rattle it is
gargling and shaking as it it ends
itself it's it's struggling so I see I
see that the sun rising I think we're
heading in a good direction but it
doesn't mean there's gonna be some
hardships along the way thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time